هل يعقل ما قام به هذا الطيار؟،
فهو لم يكن في جولة تدريبية،
بل كان في حرب حياة أو موت،
حرب وجودية لوطنه أمام المحتل،....
الطيار المجنون، مع مناورات خارقة للعادة،
يواجه عدوه كما لو كانت تلك هي المواجهة الأخيرة،
يقوم بمبارزات انتحارية،
يجعل العدو يتعجب من شجاعته،
فمن هو هذا الطيار الذي جعل الجيش الإسرائيلي
يرتعد خوفا من مواجهته؟
....
هو ملك الجو وسيد حروب السماء،
اللواء طيار أحمد كمال المنصوري،
ابن الجمهورية العربية المصرية،
لقبته إسرائيل بالطيار المجنون،
لشدة جنون ما يقوم به من مناورات جوية،
فقد تجاوز الرقم القياسي الأمريكي للطلعات الجوية،
بقيامه ب٥٢ طلعة جوية في ١٨ يوما فقط،
(مناورة الموت المحقق)
بعد هزيمة مصر في حرب ٦٧ جاءت حرب أكتوبر
كفرصة للانتقام، وعندما انطلق المنصوري في طلعته الجوية
تفاجأ بطائرة إسرائيلية تحلق خلفه
وتحاول ضربه بصواريخها،
عندها قرر هذا المجنون عمل مناورة الموت الأخيرة التي ينفذها الطيارون
عند نفاذ فرصهم بالنجاة، وجه المجنون طائرته إلى الأسفل
وانطلق بسرعة كبيرة وقبل وصوله للأرض
اندلعت هالة عظيمة من الأتربة والغبار بفعل محرك الطائرة،
عندها اعتقد الطيار الإسرائيلي أن المجنون قد انتحر،
لكن المجنون
كان له رأي آخر
وعاد قبل أن يحط على الأرض وانطلق للأعلى بسرعة الصاروخ،
وجاء من خلف عدوه وأطلق عليه صاروخين وقضى عليه،
ما لذي فعله هذا المجنون؟!!!!
..
(مع المجنون الشجاعة غلبت الكثرة )
أمر للطيار المنصوري ورفيقه الشاب حسن لطفي بتنفيذ طلعة جوية
للتصدي لهجوم ٦ طائرات إسرائيلية،
وقامت معركة جوية من أطول المعارك الجوية في التاريخ بوقت دام ل١٣ دقيقة
رغم أن المعارك الجوية لا تمتد لأكثر من ٣دقائق عادة،
بدأت المناورة وسرعان ما أسقط المنصوري طائرة الاستطلاع الإسرائيلية،
لكن الطائرات الإسرائيلية كانت تحمل في الطائرة الواحدة
أضعاف الصواريخ التي يحملها المنصوري ولطفي،
وعند نفاد صواريخ المنصوري وزميله، وإطلاق وابل من الصواريخ من أعداءها،
اقترح المنصوري على لطفي استخدام طريقة الكمي كاز اليابانية،
وهي ما نفذها لطفي فانطلق بسرعة كبيرة نحو إحدى الطائرات
,صدم بها ليستشهد لطفي ويموت من في الطائرة الأخرى،
أما المنصوري فلم يبقى له وقود إلا ما يكفيه ل٣٠ ثانية فقط،
عندها قرر المجنون الهبوط في طريق أصغر بكثير من مهبط الطائرات
لكنه كان آخر حل بالنسبة له،
وبسرعة٤٠٠كم في الساعة هبط المجنون ولم يتوقف إلا على بعد أمتار قليلة جدا
من إحدى الحافلات،  لحقت به الطائرات الصهيونية محاولة اصطياده
لكنه كان قد دخل بالفعل في محيط مضادات الطائرات المصرية،
فلاذت الطائرات الإسرائيلية بالفرار ونجى الطيار المجنون من موت محتم،
مغامرة المنصوري لم تنتهي بعد فبعد هبوطه ذهب إلى كتيبة في لواء المشاة ميكانيكي،
لكنهم اعتقدوا أنه طيار إسرائيلي فانهالوا عليه بالضرب وكسروا عموده الفقري،
ثم عرفوا لاحقا أنه طيار مصري ونقلوه إلى المشفى فورا،،،
...
وأنتم مشاهدونا هل سمعتم بطيار مجنون يفعل ما فعله المنصوري؟،
وهل قام المنصوري ببطولات أخرى غير هذه
??